so you're shopping the series around
you're looking for a production company
or you know it's been sold desired
actually nobody but we want to sell it
to Netflix we want to sell it to
somebody else I want to be involved in
that to a History Channel because I I
know what a fantastic story this is it
sounds like it and and it's just the
kind of story that is perfect for a time
for this time african-american hero
which i think is is timely you know I'm
a white guy so I am I understand that my
kind of guys pretty much run Hollywood
for a long time I think it's time that
changed but the story theme here is
about contravening the rules is about
new heroes so I think it's a great
chance to show a real guy you know I
mean his real life was so insanely cool
that she really couldn't make it up so
it's a great it's a great idea and I
know it's gonna sell so where did you go
to start shopping it around I know you
said it's already been sold but can you
take a step back there are well as since
it's happening right now I can't tell
exactly we're going short but we're
looking at channels we're looking at
channels that have names that have
channel in the name that's also yes and
the big companies I mean look there's 14
billion dollars worth of money now in
the three in the two fields internet
platform and cable there's 14 billion
dollars worth of money chasing stories
right now and it's funny because Susie's
tells you sis don't say it's easy it's
not easy to you know it's so hard and
and and you know you've gotta be
experienced and that's all true
this isn't Hollywood's not like there's
not streets paved with gold right it's
extremely difficult still to sell
anything in this business and it'd be
silly to say it's not but you know this
is the most exciting time
I think in history for television at
least in the US now I'm going over to
South Africa in a couple of weeks to
lecture over there at the Durban film
mark I'm also getting remarried we're
not married to having another ceremony
but and with that and the South America
the South African television market I
think is is is growing the I've just
been working with the guy in Brazil a
big soap opera star down there who wants
to do a serial for Netflix I think
worldwide television is just on fire but
the interesting thing is this miniseries
John Jeff Johnson the miniseries form in
television is probably the closest to a
movie form television offers what do I
mean by that a miniseries like what
you'll see in the assassination of
Gianni Versace and trust these are long
movies the television miniseries are
like long movies rather than TV serials
now I just have worked on and been paid
for a crime drama serial for television
which is not a miniseries we'll talk
about that too but the miniseries form
is like a long movie why is that because
you have wounded characters who at the
end of the miniseries have healed or
they bled out one or the other but they
have an arc okay
and that miniseries arc is just like a
long movie so with Jack Johnson he's a
superhero but he still had a journey you
so you get a progression in the story I
mean for instance a necessity of Gianni
Versace you've got a wounded guy Andrew
Cunanan was a wounded guys dad wounded
him and and his wound never healed but
he tried to heal it and so you saw this
it was like a like a 7 episode long
movie so it had a BMOC which is we can
talk about that too in it so when I'm
writing miniseries if you're a tell if
you're a movie writer who wants to go
into television you should think about
as a
in writing a miniseries because it'll
give you the opportunity to use all your
movie chops but in a television form
that lets you transition into television
because you need to have a character or
sight characters who are bleeding at the
beginning who get mentors and wound
rippers all through it and then they
learn the theme of the show towards the
end and then they either heal or don't
and that's what a miniseries gives you
that a serial television show doesn't
give you in serial television obviously
the wounded person just keeps bleeding
all through it for 100 episodes but
miniseries offer you the form a lot of
the forms of a movie in a television 7
my new sharp objects
I think debuted on Sunday I didn't watch
it I never even heard of it oh okay so
it's a Gillian Flynn and I hope I'm
saying her name correctly all the writer
of gone girl and I guess she wrote this
story from cuz I started just listening
to some interviews before she wrote gone
girl these other stories and it's about
a wounded character it's a female and
she said she's very wounded and has
issues but she's likable and she thought
that was interesting that for this
character had to be defended that she
was likable because she kind of said
well Walter White does he have to be
likable you know some of these other you
know Tony Soprano does he have to be
likable I would argue they are likable
okay but but sympathetic is actually
more important than likability if you
look at Tony Soprano he's a good example
it's old now but I think it's the most
brilliant television ever made I I think
if you haven't seen Sopranos you should
watch it okay because it's still the
most Burley it's like Shakespeare
Tony Soprano is a murderer he's a
horrible human being and that we love
him why we love him because he's God
this deep wound in him and it comes from
his mother and the entire first season
of The Sopranos is about this horrible
mother and how awful she is to Tony
and even though when he tries to kill
her on the gurney when she's there
rolling her out of the out of the
nursing home she's going he's trying to
litter time to get her with a pole where
our sympathies are with Tony why well
here's a big secret of the anti-hero
which I'll tell you which I talked about
earlier anti-heroes are great guys who
turned bad for sympathetic reasons right
for sympathetic reasons Michael Colleoni
becomes a horrible man why he's saving
his dad he's saving his family right
Tony Soprano is a horrible guy but we
like him why because he wants to save
his family he wants it the first season
of Tony's panels we've seen if he's the
Ducks are leaving his pawn his kids are
leaving the nest right he's trying to
get his mom saved into it into a home
check odd I leave me alone you're a
horrible human being so the great secret
antihero is to make the villains and the
people around them worse and less
likable than the hero themselves so Tony
Soprano's mom is the most miserable
horrible human being ever conceived on
television chase says that he's based on
his own mom but so we love Tony because
his mom is just so awful and we think
God poor guy no wonder he turned into a
murdering psychopath
his mom is awful so that's the critical
thing about making someone sympathetic
and and also likable yes it's important
but to make them sympathetic you simply
make the other people around them worse
Michael Corleone II had to save his dad
nobody else would do it
his brother couldn't do it he had these
terrible villains around him that were
shooting his entire family he had to
save his family and in doing so he
eventually lost his family right just
like Tony Soprano Tony Soprano ends up
killing his nephew ends up killing of
people all around him probably ends up
having his it was somebody shot in that
final restaurant scene around him but
we have great sympathy for him because
we see his wounds the wounds are
everything wounds are why we love a
character and if when you first start
out writing a story you should show me
your hero or your character's wounds
second they get on screen the second
there on screen show me the wound that's
how you get somebody to be likeable you
get the note your characters not
likeable which you get all the time from
producer that's how to make them
likeable keeps you on bleeding
you